-Hey, Charlize.
Nice to see you again.
-Hi. Nice to see you.
How are you?
-I'm well. Obviously,
I would prefer to be
seeing you in person.
I do appreciate
you making the time.
Are you having
an enjoyable summer?
-Yes, I am. Listen, I mean,
not without mentioning
everything that we've
been going through,
I will say it's been
really, really nice
to spend time with my kids
and to just be home.
I'm always craving more of that.
So I've taken
full advantage of that.
-And it should be noted
that when you have
a big movie like this,
someone like you
who's the star of it
would have to be doing
so much press on the road.
It must be kind of nice to
just be able to do it from home.
-Yeah. I don't think we're
going to go back to the other.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
I mean, it makes sense
to have to leave home
for six months to make a movie,
but it always seems like
such a bummer
to have to then leave home
for another two months
to talk about it.
-Yeah, I don't know.
I might disagree with you.
I'm trying to figure out
how I can just do
everything from here.
-Oh, even the movie?
Well, I should stress
that I feel like
I really enjoyed this movie.
I loved the comic
it was based on.
I feel like "The Old Guard,"
if you shot it at home,
would be considerably worse.
-[ Laughs ]
Now, that's a good friend.
You just gave me
the honest God truth,
so I will take that.
-You, uh, play one of
a group of immortal soldiers.
-Yeah.
-Your character may be,
um, 6,000-plus years old.
Ya look great.
I don't know what the secret is.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Do you ever -- Like,
playing a character like this,
did you think about what
it would actually be like?
Would you be somebody
who would be in for another
6,000 years of living?
-Mnh. I don't know about that.
I think, you know,
when you just think about it,
my reaction would be,
"Oh, my gosh!
More time
with people that I love."
Like, of course,
that sounds really nice.
But, ultimately, I think having
to live for a very long time
must feel incredibly lonely.
And I think the idea
of losing people that you love
over and over and over again,
I would have a really
hard time with that.
-Yeah, and the movie,
it should be noted --
This is a super-fun
action movie.
But it's also really sad
at times,
and I think it does a nice job
of looking at that, as well.
I also want to give you
a shout-out for this --
As an action-movie star,
which, let's be honest,
you fully are now.
I feel like
you are at the forefront
of fight scenes that take place
in enclosed places.
I feel like you've had some
really good stairway fights
in some films.
This has an airplane fight,
a hallway fight.
You're getting very good
at close fighting.
-Wow. Thank you.
You're just coming
with so many compliments.
Can we just FaceTime
every morning?
Can I start my day with you?
-Yeah.
I would super be down for it.
Yeah.
-It is fun. It is actually --
The challenge when you have
a set piece kind of dictate
the space that you're going to
be able to utilize,
it's really fun to have that.
Um, yeah.
I mean, listen,
I am inspired by fights.
Like, you know the bathroom
fight in "Mission"?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I mean,
I love fights like that.
So, um, I think it's always --
The set piece plays
a huge part in it.
And when you have
a lot of space,
I think you lose
some of that intensity
of, like, people being
right on top of each other
in the hand-to-hand
combat style.
So, where else can we
have a fight scene?
Hmm.
-That's true.
I feel like --
I mean, you guys --
'Cause I feel like there's
obviously the bathroom fight
scene in "Mission."
And then this has
an airplane fight scene.
But have we seen a really good
airplane-bathroom fight scene?
-[ Laughs ]
-That would be like --
Now we're making it as small --
-Now we are literally just --
It's body-to-body contact.
-Yeah, exactly.
-That...amazing, though.
-No one wins in
an airplane-bathroom fight.
That is one of the adages.
-Yeah.
No, everyone's a loser
in that for sure.
-You have an ax in this film.
And, uh, you seem
very comfortable with the ax.
Does something --
Does work go into looking
like you know what
you're doing with an ax?
-[ Laughs ]
It's a mixture of work,
and then also I was advised
by my incredible fight
coordinator, Danny Hernandez,
to just walk around with the ax
at all times.
So he gave me an ax.
It was rubber, but it still
looked very, very real.
And he just said, "Listen, just
keep it with you at all times."
Like, he's like,
"Even if you go for a drive,
if you go to a restaurant" --
This was back before lockdown.
"Like, if you go gro--
Just have it in the car
even if you just hold it, or if
you're in the kitchen cooking,
like, just twirl it
a little bit."
So, you know, I take direction
very seriously.
So I did that.
And then I remember one night
I went out to dinner,
and the valet
pulled my car around,
and he just got out of the car,
and he just -- his face just --
He didn't say anything, and
I couldn't quite understand it.
I was like, "Did I tip him?
Is it because I --
Did I not tip enough?"
And then I got in the car, and
the big ax was just lying there.
And I was like, "Ohh!"
-Yeah.
And it should be noted
it's not the kind of ax
where somebody might've thought
you were doing some woodworking.
It's definitely, like --
It's definitely a menace ax.
-Yeah.
It's like a prehistoric, like...
-...double-faced ax
that just looks like it is going
to hurt you by looking at it.